my name is knock dr. John Neff assistant
professor of pediatrics at Johns Hopkins
it is my feeling that it is no longer
necessary to perform routine preschool
or infant smallpox vaccination I'm
Samuel Katz professor and chairman of
the department of pediatrics at Duke
University I believe that our nation's
freedom from smallpox rest upon the
widespread use of smallpox vaccine I'm
dr. Paul Worley it's my job today to try
to resolve these two opposed points of
view
welcome to the exploration of concepts
and controversies in modern medicine one
of a series of programs dedicated to
examining the uncertain candidly
recognizing that much of today's
teaching is necessarily based upon
opinion and at the opinions of eminent
physicians in a given field vary widely
the national medical audiovisual Center
believes that openly airing such
opposing views is a basic responsibility
of medical communications dr. Paul
Worley Hastings professor of pediatrics
at the University of Southern California
School of Medicine will act as moderator
for this presentation for many years the
physicians of this country and the
workers in public health have been
emphasizing the need for vaccination for
children and particularly infants and
preschool children to provide a basic
immunity against smallpox we also have
been urging immunization at intervals
for particular types of health workers
for transportation workers and at
intervals we have also urged RIA muniz
ation of all citizens of this country
whether they plan international travel
or not the immunization against smallpox
is the earliest and one of the most
effective prophylaxis agents against any
of the communicable diseases however
during recent years the ball game seems
to be changed the rules are somewhat
different and perhaps there are
differences with respect to some of the
threats I would first like to before
getting our combatants into the fray I'd
like to first turn to see what's
happening with regard to the
international picture and see what's
happening to smallpox on on the world
wide scale because I think this is
important to us as we develop our our
story today as you will see in 1945
smallpox
I was present throughout virtually all
of South America 1945 you'll note is the
lighter shaded together with the darker
shaded areas through a spread throughout
all of South America throughout all of
Africa through the middle east through
Southeast Asia and down including Malaya
and many of the countries in the South
Pacific during the next period of time
from 1955 through 1965 we see additional
changes taking place here earlier period
is in lighter color the subsequent
period and darker color and here you see
that these areas originally involved
very solidly have have become
substantially smaller and I think it's
important to note that the areas
involved here although they are solidly
colored may have some differences with
respect to specific areas within those
countries where smallpox remains a
problem also another area that I hope we
can point up today is data concerning
the risk of vaccination and data
concerning the possibility of other
means of the prevention of smallpox
should it be introduced into this
country I think at this time I would
like to turn to our first combatant this
morning dr. Neff and see how he would
like to develop his particular position
well I think there can be no question
now that smallpox vaccination has been
one agent which has been responsible for
eradicated smallpox from large areas of
the world but I think that it can be no
question also that by present-day
standards smallpox vaccine or as a vac
vaccine is a very poor vaccine and I
think for two reasons it's a poor
vaccine for one reason the duration of
immunity that is afforded by your
smallpox vaccination is relatively short
in duration and probably absolute
immunity to smallpox from the vaccine is
no longer than three years number two
there are a significant number of
locations that are associated with this
particular vaccine and a significant
amount of mortality now for a long time
in this country we've practiced routine
of preschool and infant vaccinations so
that within this country about ninety
percent of the people have been advanced
inated at least one time in their life
and it's also true since nineteen forty
nine there have been no cases of
smallpox imported into the United States
but for this we paid a real price based
on surveys that we've done in 1968 1963
and review of the death certificates
there can be no question that there are
at least seven deaths a year as a result
of our smallpox vaccination policy and
the other question that this brings up
is this really been the reason that we
have been free of smallpox if you look
carefully in terms of the immunity of
the nation you'll find that eighty
percent of the population has not been
vaccinated within three years and
therefore are not absolutely protected
against smallpox and fifty percent have
not been vaccinated for greater than
fifteen years and probably have little
or no protection at all the smallpox
well as the epidemiology of smallpox is
such that this can be prevented from
entering into our country and I think
has been not because our population has
been well vaccinated but because our
travelers are well vaccinated and that I
think that the other thing is that there
is a very focal disease and that the
secondary cases can be predicted and
they're not going to sweep through the
nation as other diseases perhaps measles
or whatnot but it's the secondary cases
are very focal and occur in hospital
personnel and family contact and I think
that all we have to do in this country
is number one immunize our travelers and
that will keep smallpox out and number
to identify those risks those population
at high risk and those of your hospital
personnel and your family contacts and
it is not necessary to perform routine
and smallpox vaccination thank you dr.
Neff I think you've summed up the
arguments very nicely here and I think
at this point we should turn to dr. Sam
Katz and see what he has to say
concerning the need to continue our
present position
I think that it's important to recall
that little over 30 years ago there were
at least 15,000 cases of smallpox in the
United States and that as dr. Neff has
pointed out we have had none basically
over the last 20 years this is an
admirable record and it's one which I
think we all wish to persist and defend
the question which is basic to this is
weighing a known dimension against the
conjecture we agree I think dr. Worley
dr. Neff and I that much of this
admirable record stems from the
widespread use of vaccine we cannot
provide any data on what would happen if
we abandon this widespread immunization
program we can look at the experience in
other countries in 1948 Great Britain
abandoned the legal compulsion to
smallpox vaccination over subsequent
years they've had hundreds of cases of
smallpox which have resulted from
importation and in this regard I would
disagree with dr. Neff that the
vaccination of our travelers will
protect us against importation because
in most cases it has not been natives
returning to their nation who have
brought the initial case it has been a
native of a country in which the disease
remains endemic as shown on dr. Willie's
chart in this regard then I think we
cannot close the door and rely solely
upon the immunization of our travelers I
think we have to accept the fact that we
can't control a great deal of the
population and that in the jet age it's
very simple for a person to be
incubating smallpox come from Asia
Africa or Brazil to the United States
with no overt disease and introduce the
disease within a very short period of
time the other feature is I think our
physicians are unable to recognize the
disease anymore because we're free of it
so this reliance on quick slaughtering
of an outbreak is I think a bit
optimistic under present circumstances
I think that dark cats is summed up very
nicely many of the arguments for
continuing our present policies and I
think we have several points that we
ought to discuss in depth in order to
bring out some of these divergent types
of opinions now the first question
though I think we might bounce around a
bit is concerns the probability of
introducing smallpox into the United
States with our present surveillance
systems with our present levels of
immunization and so on and I think that
the communicable disease Center and a
lot of a number of other organizations
such as World Health Organization and
the governments of the health services
at many other countries have studied
this problem very carefully John you've
seemed to minimize the risk of bringing
smallpox in via either Americans abroad
or nationals from other countries well
yes well I think the important point
here and I would disagree with dr. Katz
it's not the Nationals of another
country but it's generally the Nationals
of the country to which smallpox is
introduced I think one of the reasons is
that smallpox now in the present pattern
of eradication is being driven back into
relatively remote areas and it is not
the cities and it's not the travelers
that are have a tendency to come in
contact with with cases of smallpox and
I think that one can look at our at our
own history for the past 20 years of our
protection has not prevented smallpox
from spreading in the United States
actually we've never been challenged we
haven't had an importation into the
United States how do you know you
haven't been challenged well this is a
this is a good question i think that we
have a very good surveillance system at
the CDC at the National CDC and any
suspected case is looked at by a person
who is capable of diagnosing smallpox
and differentiating this from Jeff I'll
agree for that now John I think you can
honest about this without denigrating
the medical profession we've not had the
experience in this country looking at
small costs even the best physicians
acquainted with tropical medicine would
be perfectly frank to say that a bad
case of chickenpox is impossible to
differentiate from a mile or a more
severe case of smallpox I think we can
all recall a few years ago when this was
exactly what happened when a lady from
Ghana was thought to have smallpox and
actually had varicella secondly that
emphasized the fact that our laboratory
facilities though they may in rare
instances be attuned to this are not
constantly challenged with making the
diagnosis of smallpox so that they can
be confusion even with the laboratory
support that's required for the
diagnosis in a country where small box
is not occurring so that I have no peace
of mind about our ability to diagnose
smallpox either clinically or laboratory
wise at the drop of a hat in New York
San Francisco Seattle Boston any port
where the disease might enter tomorrow
this is certainly a an area where I
think we let it remain far apart I
wonder for two or three things that we
could agree with here now certainly we
haven't had any widespread occurrence of
smallpox in this country for many years
are we agreed on this point we agree now
it is possible that a case or two cases
or an occasional case one or two three a
year or something like this may come
into the country may occur without
spread could conceivably misdiagnosed I
would I would say this again is only
conjecture but to be if I wanted to use
such conjecture I would use it to
reinforce the concept that if this is
happening periodically our level of
immunization has been sufficient to
dampen the spread of disease I don't
like John's use of the word a poor
vaccine there are problems with smallpox
vaccine I think there's good work going
on to improve the vaccine but this
business of three
cheers and Prevention of disease is one
thing prevention of death is the other
you're emphasizing death as your big
fear with smallpox vaccine I think you
must emphasize death as your fear with
the disease now the mortality rate with
important implication in Europe has been
anywhere from ten to forty percent in
various outbreaks as far as protection
from smallpox vaccine is concerned if
memory serves me correctly if you've had
immunization even within twenty years
though you may get disease there has not
been mortality from disease I think in
the long run that's our best protection
is against death from the disease let me
mention something here I think that when
you're talking about the deaths
secondary to the smallpox vaccine that
you are talking in the range of seven a
year which means over the 20 years that
we have been free of smallpox we've had
probably in the range of a hundred to
two hundred deaths as a result of the
vaccine I will take an awfully large
epidemic of smallpox to be able to equal
that mortality John before we get into
that area let's let's clear up one or
two points where I think we have some
real problems one of them is is in the
area of the real effectiveness of this
vaccine and dr. Katz indicated that the
immunity as far as death is concerned
seems to be pretty solid for at least 20
or 25 years after vaccination death
would be unusual other cases do occur
but that there is some protection still
conferred after 10 15 20 or even 25
years you have a diminished risk of
acquiring the disease although for three
years or something like that it's
virtually solid this really is pretty
good vaccine I think what you meant was
a poor vaccine in terms of hazards in
comparison with benefits in this
particular frame in this country right
and I think that if you're just going to
look at that aspect alone that I think
would be very surprising if this
particular vaccine passed the
regulations that we the stringent
regulations that we have
let's look at the deaths that occur it
seems to me that as we examine them and
this is from dr. Neffs own publications
that at least fifty percent of them are
in a true sense preventable but as
individuals receive smallpox vaccine for
whom we know it is an untoward
immunization procedure a child with
eczema or the sibling of a child with
eczema a patient with a malignancy
involving the immune mechanisms a
patient on immunosuppressive drugs these
are patients we know will have trouble
with smallpox vaccine these latter ones
or any live virus vaccine this is an
accident of medical supervision or a
public health supervision I don't think
the vaccine should be incriminated on
this basis rather we should in criminate
ourselves as having poor judgment in
using it improperly as far as the
children are concerned with eczema I
think we're aware that there are efforts
to improve and to come up with a strain
of vaccinia that might not cause eczema
vaccin Adam but I would again get back
to the point of blanketing importations
it seems to me that the sort of crash
program you have when suddenly the news
hits that a case of smallpox has been
imported you're more apt to get poor
discrimination in the use of vaccine as
you get the panic situation run around
and vaccinate everyone who might have
been exposed easily there you're in a
situation where you're more likely to
immunize the inappropriate individuals
then you are in an ongoing program where
good judgment can be encouraged well
there are two things and let that you
bring up one is the prevent ability of
the of the complications and san lee i
have taken your stand in the past that
if you've got a large number of these
complications are preventable but the
thing that bothers me is that when you
actually look at these at the
complications that occur that could be
preventable that's been known a long
time that you shouldn't vaccinate a
child with eczema or a family contact
with eczema yet at the same time between
nineteen sixty three and nine
68 when there's been a lot of publicity
you still have the same number of cases
of eczema vaccine autumn the same can be
said about vaccinating people with any
type of immunological deficiency disease
that the difference between 63 and 68 in
the data when you would hopefully see a
reduction there seems to be no change
and that it's just an accident I think
of practice that some of these people
get vaccinated well then you're willing
to take that inevitability of change and
bargain that against the unknown factor
of all right we're defeated we cut all
so that is what you're saying basically
are you then willing to bargain for the
unknown which is the only way to prevent
those few deaths which are tragic I
agree that the only way to prevent it is
then to take the gamble which we can't
provide any data on of how many cases of
smallpox would we have were we to do to
do away with routine immunization and
how many cases of these same
complications would we have in the use
of crash program vaccinations other
things up a very interesting point that
I think we ought to try to to cover with
our in our next session here I think one
is why hasn't there been a decrease
because everyone knows that that you
shouldn't vaccinate a child with eczema
and why are we continuing to have this
same frequency of involvement here I
think another thing that I'd like to see
you to spar over is is there really a
greater risk in vaccinating the
individual who has a primary vaccination
as an adolescent or as a young adult
because here is another part of the
argument and I think an important part
if for example we're going to have an
unusually high risk of complications in
vaccinating young adults for overseas
travel for whatever then whatever
position we take I think has to take
that part into consideration and I think
your implication this would go I would
accept it to support my argument we
don't do this absolutely really and
there's nothing I think we do from the
Netherlands we do from other countries
those complications that are not
preventable what it encephalitis would
be the one we would say maybe we can
prevent eczema vaccinate oh we don't
know enough about post vaxcel
encephalitis to even discuss its
pathogenesis we don't know how to
prevent it we do have at least data
which suggests that the older the age
group having their primary experience
the more likely one is to encounter post
axial encephalitis I would certainly use
that as an argument in favor of
continuing childhood or infancy
immunization well Sam I think that
you've got to talk about the figures
that come from the United States because
it's there's a tremendous amount of
discrepancy in terms we don't have the
store data favila well I I think we do
Sam to some degree it's true that right
now about ninety percent of your adults
have been vaccinated so you see very few
primaries but over the over the past 20
years since the Second World War about
ten percent of your military recruits
our primary factor needs and this comes
to about two million military recruits
that have been vaccinated and it happens
to be that there have been no reported
cases of post factum encephalitis since
the second world war in that group now
it's possible that maybe one or two have
been missed but you certainly don't have
the same type of experience that they've
been having in the Netherlands where
it's 14 thousand what is that got it now
again on how many are truly primary
vaccinees about ten percent Sam ten to
thirteen percent so that if you work
this out over twenty year period it
comes in the range of 20 million primary
vaccinations in the system where you
have a pretty good surveillance for
complication like I can't quite follow
how you're getting 20 million but I'm
sorry two million excuse me Sam Canadian
yeah left you turn it if you turn around
the other way of course your statistics
on on the severe complications in
childhood amount to about one per
million libraries and of those one we
would say fifty percent perhaps are
preventable so it's a half of one per
million which brings it down to probably
the same rail I think you're bargaining
for it well it's it's variable I think
that it's
least a half per million in 1963 there
were five post factual encephalitis 46
million primary so this is nearly one
per million primary vaccination and this
was for primaries presumably in young
age rye individuals into us right
particularly well I would certainly
submit that we have difficulty in
transposing data from one nation to
another but I'm tremendously impressed
with the reliability of the data from
the Netherlands with their experience
with armed forces groups who did not
have immunization against smallpox in
childhood and their data is certainly
very striking as to the difference in
incidents of post vaxcel encephalitis
when groups in their late teens or early
20s our first immunized I don't know
that we have that sort of experience in
an ongoing prospective fashion they've
directed attention to this as we know
dr. van de Naude ER and his associates
have followed this carefully I don't
know that we've had any such careful
surveillance no and I but I think that
saying Great Britain there has been
careful surveillance and for and their
experience is very much analogous to
what our experience has been and it's
and there's four revox an ease and the
upper primary vaccinees and the adults
it's in the range of 2.8 cases of post
facto encephalitis per million so this
is a little bit more than we have here
but it's at least in our ballpark rather
than in the Netherlands so it depends on
what country data you quote and I think
that when you're making these decisions
you have to look at your own country and
make the decisions as best you can based
on our experience and I think that if
you act in the same place where if we
look to our country we can only look for
conjectures or extrapolations we don't
have the comparative data I suppose that
the question we're asking one another is
do we want to acquire well we're the
point where we can justify a change
which will provide us with the data are
we too concerned about sticking path the
way we are or are we going to get into
trouble if we try the other way Thank
You dark stressful
or summarizing very nicely the various
points of view and information behind
the present position regarding the use
of this vaccine and thank you dr. Neff
for doing a beautiful job in summarizing
the arguments toward changing our
position I think that we in considering
the present posture with regard to the
use of vaccinia and the prevention of
smallpox as a routine procedure in this
country must keep these various points
that have been very a bleep resented
very firmly in mind one part of the
argument revolves around the likelihood
of introduction of smallpox cases into
this country and the probability of
spread once introduced the data here I
think are quite clear in that it seems
unreasonable to assume that this is
going to be something that will be
happening frequently in the future
however the chance occurrence still
remains a possibility the second area
that was brought out I think very nicely
by our combatants is the problem of a
risk associated with the use of this
most effective vaccine a number of
patients have developed and they can be
expected to continue to develop serious
complications another facet of the risk
that I think was very important to bring
out is what will happen if we no longer
immunize infants and our immunizing only
those adults who are involved in
international travel and other
situations that might put them at risk
thank you very much for the opportunity
to be with you
we've liked dr. Samuel Katz dr. John F
dr. Paul Willie for their interesting
analysis of a critical problem in
patient care in subsequent programs we
shall continue to record equally
significant concepts and controversies
in modern medicine the opinions
expressed on this program do not
necessarily constitute endorsement by
the Department of Health Education and
Welfare the Public Health Service or its
constituents
you